moon pie i've got a little treat for you
[Music]
chocolate chip right out of the oven
good that means they're sterile
why don't you come on out here and have
a couple
i can't do that okay i tell you what i'm
gonna just
put them right out here and you can come
out and get one
when you're ready how about that i'm
gonna put them down right
here
[Music]
come on
listen to me buster okay you
are a lot of things sheldon you are cute
smart hygienic
but most of all you
are a texan so so
texans aren't afraid of nothing
rattlesnakes indians the mexican
army
do you imagine that sam houston was
scared of a little old cold
no jim bowie
no spacek
i guess not you're damn right because
they're
texans through and through now i want
you to quit hiding in this plastic
bubble and i want you to come out here
and eat your cookies out in the world
like a man
like a texan man
[Music]
i'm impressed me too
i thought i'd lost him at sissy's basic
as you can see my meemaw successfully
lured me back into the world
by reminding me of my brave texas
ancestors
their blood ran through my veins i was a
true
son of the lone star state albeit a true
son with an incredibly fragile immune
system
i woke up the next morning with a
temperature of 102
and a head packed full of mucus
however there was a silver lining
soft kitty warm kitty little ball of fur
happy kitty sleepy kitty purr
purple sing it again mom
first blow your nose
soft kitty warm kitty little ball of fur
happy kitty sleepy kitty purr perper
[Music]